This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanta. We're a couple of weeks into the new year, and perhaps you've already fallen behind on your resolutions to floss every day, eat healthy, exercise. Today, we're going to help you get back on track. We'll talk about the psychology of resolutions, and Dan Pink will join me to offer tips to help you stick to your goals.
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。新年已经过去几周了，也许你每天用牙线洁牙、健康饮食、锻炼身体的新年决心已经开始落空了。今天，我们将帮助你重回正轨。我们将探讨决心的心理学，丹·平克也会加入我的节目，为你提供坚持目标的建议。
Before we get to that though, I wanted to take a few minutes to talk about something happening on my own staff. It's 2016 and I have not smoked for two minutes. This is Max Nestrak. He's been working at Hidden Brain for the last couple of months. His resolution was to quit smoking. I decided I wanted to help. I told Max to do three things based on findings from social science research. We'll come back to one of them later in this episode and we'll have another episode in a few months to discuss how and whether the interventions worked.
不过在此之前，我想花几分钟时间聊聊我团队里正在发生的一件事。现在是2016年，我戒烟已经两分钟了。这是马克斯·内斯特拉克。过去几个月他一直在《隐藏的大脑》工作。他的新年决心是戒烟。我决定帮他一把。根据社会科学研究的发现，我让马克斯做三件事。本期节目稍后我们会回访其中一件事，几个月后我们还会有另一期节目，讨论这些干预措施是如何运作的以及是否有效。
Max has been recording an audio diary since the day he quit. Today is day one. I've noticed that time goes really slow when you're quitting smoking. Day one of quitting smoking continues. It's like this mental obsession. So you're kind of like, oh, should I have a granola bar? No, I want a house cigarette. Should I go for a walk?
自从马克斯戒烟那天起，他就一直在录制音频日记。今天是第一天。我发现戒烟的时候时间过得真的好慢。戒烟的第一天还在继续。这就像是一种精神上的痴迷。所以你心里会想，噢，我该吃个谷物棒吗？不，我想抽根烟。我该去散步吗？
No, I want to have a cigarette. I'm really looking forward to going to bed. And it's like 2 p.m. You're on a trolley and you're really warm and you're wearing your winter coat and scarf. And when you're having a craving, you just, you don't think that you're ever going to feel differently or have felt differently.
不，我想抽根烟。我真的很盼望上床睡觉。然而现在才下午两点。你坐在一辆电车上，身上觉得很热，还穿着冬衣系着围巾。当你烟瘾犯的时候，你就是不会觉得这种感觉会改变，或者以前曾有过不同的感觉。
It's super crowded and it's super hot in this trolley and that sort of feels like you have to love the burn almost. You know what I mean? Like it sucks, it hurts and you just kind of lean into it and you're like yeah, like this is what quitting feels like and yeah so I'm loving the burn right now. Oh, okay, it's like three minutes away from being 48 hours, so it's at the end of day two. It's day three, and I still haven't smelled. There were some dark moments today. Uh-huh. Okay, it's day five, and I just got back from a run day eight, which means I've made it an entire week, which feels like such an accomplishment.
电车上超级拥挤，热得不行，这种感觉就好像你几乎必须去享受这种煎熬。你知道我的意思吗？就像这糟透了，这很痛苦，而你只能去咬牙承受，心里想着：对，戒烟就是这种感觉，没错，所以我现在正享受这种煎熬呢。哦，好吧，再过大约三分钟就满48小时了，所以这已经是第二天结束的时候了。今天是第三天，我居然还没抽烟。今天有一些至暗时刻。嗯哼。好吧，今天是第五天，我刚跑完步回来；今天是第八天，这意味着我已经坚持整整一周了，这感觉真是一项巨大的成就。
So it's day 12 and when I woke up this morning, I was just feeling so grateful that, you know, the first thing I don't have to go have a cigarette. Hidden Brain's new assistant, Max Nestrak. We're going to begin today by exploring why we make resolutions in the first place. That's important in understanding why we so often fail to stick to them and how we can do better. If you listen to public radio, you know that I often sit down with a host of the daily news programs to talk about interesting social science research. My recent conversation with Audi Cornish of all things considered started with a host of the daily news programs to talk about interesting social science research. My recent conversation with Audie Cornish of all things considered started with a question.
今天是第12天，今天早上醒来时，我感到由衷的感激，你知道的，我睁开眼的第一件事不是去抽烟。《隐藏的大脑》新助理马克斯·内斯特拉克。我们今天要从探讨我们为什么要许下新年决心开始。这对于理解为什么我们常常无法坚持这些决心以及我们该如何做得更好至关重要。如果你收听公共广播，你就会知道我经常与日常新闻节目的主持人坐在一起，探讨有趣的社会科学研究。我最近与《综合报道》的奥迪·科尼什的对话，是从一个问题开始的……探讨有趣的社会科学研究。我最近与《综合报道》的奥迪·科尼什的对话，是从一个问题开始的。
Why do we make New Year's resolutions? Especially if we know we're just going to break them. Here with some insight on this subject as NPR's social science correspondent Shankar Vait Dantam and Shankar, you also are going to offer some advice, right, on how to make these goals more achievable. I'm going to try Audie. Okay, let's get this out of the way. First of all, why do we bother with New Year's resolutions? What's going on in our head? It's actually a great question, and I don't think we actually stop to ask that question very often. A few social science researchers recently did, Hank Chen, Dai, Catherine, Milkman, and Jason Rees at the Wharton School at the University of Pennsylvania, they asked this question, why do we make resolutions at the start of a new year?
我们为什么要做新年决心？尤其是当我们明知道自己最终会违背它们的时候。NPR的社会科学记者尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆为我们带来了一些关于这个主题的见解，尚卡尔，你也将就如何让这些目标更容易实现提供一些建议，对吗？我会试试的，奥迪。好吧，咱们先把这个放到一边。首先，我们为什么还要费劲去许下新年决心？我们脑子里到底在想什么？这其实是一个很好的问题，而且我觉得我们平时并不经常停下来问自己这个问题。宾夕法尼亚大学沃顿商学院的几位社会科学研究员——陈汉、黛、凯瑟琳·米尔克曼和杰森·里斯——最近就提出了这个问题：为什么我们在新的一年开始时许下决心？
And they think new year's resolutions are really a form of what they call mental accounting. They find that Google searches for the word diet go up dramatically at the start of a new year. But what's interesting is that it's not just at the start of the new year. Birthdays, the start of a new month, the start of a new week, federal holidays, all of these serve as what the researchers call temporal landmarks. Temporal landmarks, okay, so it's our own way of marking sort of who we are, who we were, and the beautiful butterfly.
他们认为，新年决心其实是他们所称的“心理账户”的一种形式。他们发现，在新年伊始，谷歌上搜索“节食”这个词的次数会急剧增加。但有趣的是，这种情况不仅发生在新年伊始。生日、新一个月的开始、新一周的开始、联邦假日，所有这些都被研究人员称为“时间地标”。时间地标，好吧，所以这是我们标记自己是谁、我们曾经是谁以及破茧成蝶的一种独特方式。
We can do a merge, right, when we make all these changes. Exactly, now, you know, many religions actually have explicit language describing the very same thing. So Christians, for example, say someone is born again. And this squares very well with the psychological truth about human beings, Adi, previous research by Ann Wilson and Michael Ross at the University of Waterloo, show that people tend to look down on their path selves compared to who they are now. So they say, I used to be a chump, but now I'm a chump.
当我们做出所有这些改变时，我们可以进行某种融合，对吧？没错，现在你知道，许多宗教其实都有明确的语言来描述完全相同的事情。例如，基督徒会说某人“重生”了。这与关于人类的心理真相非常契合，奥迪，滑铁卢大学的安·威尔逊和迈克尔·罗斯先前的研究表明，与现在的自己相比，人们往往会看低自己过去的形象。所以他们会说，我以前是个笨蛋，但现在的我是个大笨蛋。
So resolutions really are a way to mark this transition between the old inferior version of ourselves and the new and improved Audi Cornish 2.0. Aha, well what does this tell us about why the resolutions fail then, right? We have the energy, we have the gumption. What happens? Well, I mean if we are biased to imagine that our present cells are superior to our past cells. This actually sets us up for failure, Adi. So if I think to myself that the new and improved chunker will exercise every day and exercise self-control, but I'm really the same person that I used to be, my resolutions are likely to fail. You're basically saying this is what makes it hard to follow through. Who we want to be versus who we kind of know we are. That's exactly right. And when
因此，决心确实是标志着我们从旧的、劣质的自我版本过渡到全新改进版的“奥迪·科尼什2.0”的一种方式。哈哈，那这告诉我们为什么决心最终会失败呢？我们有精力，我们有干劲。到底发生了什么？嗯，我的意思是，如果我们带着一种偏见，想象现在的自己优于过去的自己，奥迪，这其实就为我们的失败埋下了伏笔。所以如果我心里想，焕然一新、升级版的尚卡尔每天都会锻炼并且严于律己，但我其实还是以前那个我，我的决心就很可能会失败。你基本上是说，这就是为什么难以坚持到底的原因。我们想成为的人，与我们心知肚明的自己之间的差距。完全正确。而当你
you come to sort of addressing these problems, I think the first thing to say is that awareness of the bias is actually helpful. But we can also take advantage of our tendency to see these temporal landmarks as fresh start. So for example, one thing you can do is make changes that then work automatically. So if you boost automatic deductions
着手解决这些问题时，我认为首先要说的是，意识到这种偏见其实是很有帮助的。但我们也可以利用我们把这些时间地标视为“全新开始”的倾向。例如，你可以做的一件事是做出能自动生效的改变。因此，如果你提高自动扣款额
from your paycheck to a retirement account, for example, you can make that change once on January 2nd, and it's going to last the rest of your year without you having to do anything about it. The second thing you can do is take advantage of smaller temporal landmarks, like a new month or a birthday, you can take advantage of that bias to basically say when you hit February 1st, you can now say the January version of myself is the inferior version, I have a chance now to reinvent myself in February. All right, so you know a lot about this.
比如从你的薪水中转账到退休账户，你可以在1月2日做一次这样的更改，它就会在你一年的剩余时间里持续生效，而你无需为此做任何其他事情。你可以做的第二件事是利用较小的时间地标，比如一个新的月份或一个生日，你可以利用这种偏见，基本上在2月1日到来时对自己说：1月份的我已经是劣质版本了，我现在有机会在2月份重塑自我。好了，所以你对这个很了解。
Does this mean that you have a seemingly achievable resolution for 2016 that you're willing to share? Well, I have a resolution. I'm not sure how achievable it is, Audi. And I feel this resolution very keenly right now, because like millions of other people, my sports team has done abysmally this past season. And my resolution for 2016 is to care less about football than I did in 2015. Some would say that version of you is the superior version. And it's probably not achievable.
这是否意味着你为2016年制定了一个看起来可以实现、并且愿意与大家分享的决心？嗯，我确实有一个决心。奥迪，我不确定它有多大可能实现。我现在对这个决议有着极其深刻的感受，因为和数百万其他人一样，我支持的运动队在过去这个赛季表现糟糕透顶。我2016年的决心是，少操心一点橄榄球，不像2015年那样。有些人可能会说，那个版本的你会是更好的版本。而且这大概是无法实现的。
Okay, so in the couple of weeks since I talked to Audi, I have already failed in my resolution because I have continued to follow my failing football team with the obsession that I had in 2015. So we're going to take a short break and when we come back, Dan Pink is going to help me and we are going to help you figure out ways to stick to your resolutions. Stay with us. Back now for another round of stop-what science, I'm Shankar Vedantam. I'm joined as always by Daniel Pink. He's the author of several books on human behavior, but on our show, his title is Senior Stop-Wat Science Carrespondent. Hi, Dan.
好吧，就在我和奥迪交谈后的几周内，我已经在这个决心上失败了，因为我依然像2015年那样，带着那种痴迷继续关注着我那支战绩不佳的橄榄球队。所以我们要稍作休息，回来后，丹·平克将协助我，我们将帮助大家找到坚持新年决定的方法。请继续收听。现在回到新一轮的“秒停科学”节目，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。和往常一样，和我在一起的是丹尼尔·平克。他是多本关于人类行为的书籍的作者，但在我们的节目中，他的头衔是“高级秒停科学记者”。嗨，丹。
Hey, Shankar. On stop-what science Science Carous Pondit. Hi Dan. Hey Shankar. On Stop-Wat Science, Dan and I give one another 60 seconds to summarize interesting social science research, as we approach the 60 second mark, our producers Kara and Maggie will bring the music up to drown us out just like they do with the Oscars. Our topic today is how to stick to your resolutions. I have to ask you, Dan, are you good at sticking to your resolutions? I am resolute in general, but not that good at resolutions in particular. I have a lot of resolve. Let's put it that way. Wait, so you mean that you are a resolute person who doesn't stick to your resolutions? I'm theoretically as resolute as a human being can be.
嘿，尚卡尔。在秒停科学节目中，丹和我给彼此60秒的时间来总结有趣的社会科学研究，当我们接近60秒大关时，我们的制作人卡拉和玛吉会把音乐调大来盖过我们的声音，就像他们在奥斯卡颁奖典礼上做的那样。我们今天的主题是如何坚持你的决心。我得问问你，丹，你擅长坚持自己的决心吗？我总的来说很有决心，但具体到各个决心上就不那么擅长了。我的意志力很强，咱们这么说吧。等等，你的意思是说，你是一个很有决心的人，却无法坚持自己的决心？理论上讲，作为一个人类，我能有多坚定，我就有多坚定。
As we know, theory is the only thing that actually matters on stopwatch science. Alright, Dan and I are going to help you stick to your failing or flagging New Year's resolutions. Have you found your studies, Dan? I have, and this first one earned its place on stopwatch science, Shankar, because it's the only academic paper I've ever read that cites both William James and LeBron James. Alright, can I wait to hear this? Down if you're ready, your first 60 seconds starts now.
正如我们所知，在秒停科学中，理论是唯一真正重要的东西。好了，丹和我将帮助大家坚持那些正在失败或动摇的新年决心。丹，你找到你的研究了吗？我找到了，这第一项研究赢得了它在“秒停科学”节目中的一席之地，尚卡尔，因为它是我读过的唯一一篇同时引用了威廉·詹姆斯和勒布朗·詹姆斯的学术论文。好的，我迫不及待想听听这个了！丹，如果你准备好了，你的前60秒现在开始。
Now this first study was led by Ethan Cross of the University of Michigan and shows that we can boost our performance by choosing the right pronoun. Now this research examined self-talk. That's what it's called when we talk to ourselves silently. Across several experiments, the researchers tested if changing the way we talked to ourselves could help us in nerve-wracking situations like giving a speech. Now, for this experiment, half the participants used first-person pronouns in their self-talk, saying things like, why do I feel this way? The other participants used non-first-person language,
这项由密歇根大学的伊森·克罗斯主导的最新研究表明，通过选择正确的代词，我们可以提升我们的表现。这项研究考察了“自言自语”。这就是我们默默对自己说话时的称呼。在多项实验中，研究人员测试了改变我们对自己说话的方式是否能帮助我们在诸如发表演讲等让人神经紧张的情况下表现得更好。在这个实验中，一半的参与者在自言自语时使用了第一人称代词，比如：“我为什么会有这种感觉？”另一半参与者则使用了非第一人称语言，
saying to themselves, why do you feel this way, or if I were a participant, what are the underlying causes and reasons for dance feelings? and language. Saying to themselves, why do you feel this way, or if I were a participant, what are the underlying causes and reasons for dance feelings? Over and over, non-first-person self-talk proved more effective in reducing anxiety and helping people see stressful situations as challenges rather than threats. Unlike the words I and me, second-person pronouns, and even talking about yourself in the third person like LeBron sometimes does gives us the distance to see situations more objectively and to prepare with greater confidence. I love that study, Dan. It's in some ways you know it meshes with all the work that's been done on
对自己说：“你为什么会有这种感觉？”或者“如果我是参与者，丹产生这种感觉的根本原因和理由是什么？”一遍又一遍，非第一人称的自言自语在减轻焦虑和帮助人们将压力情境视为挑战而非威胁方面被证明更有效。与“我”这个词不同，第二人称代词，甚至像勒布朗有时那样用第三人称来称呼自己，能给我们提供一种距离感，让我们能够更客观地看待情况，并以更大的自信做好准备。我喜欢这项研究，丹。在某种程度上，你知道它与围绕正念开展的所有研究不谋而合
mindfulness that basically says when you can observe yourself you actually have some distance and control over your perceptions and behavior. That's precisely what it is. It's something called self-distancing. And actually the little tricks we can use in our own lives to self-distance is something as simple as switching from first person to second person or even third person. So now Shankar, I'm going to give you a second person instruction. You have 60 seconds to give us your study. All right, let me start by saying that even though Shankar Vedanta is experiencing great anxiety about wrapping up this summary in 60 seconds, he is going to do his best to come
基本上，这些研究表明，当你能够审视自己时，你实际上就对自己的感知和行为拥有了一定的距离感和控制力。这正是它的精髓所在。这被称为“自我抽离”。实际上，我们在日常生活中可以用来实现自我抽离的小技巧非常简单，比如从第一人称切换到第二人称，甚至是第三人称。好了，尚卡尔，现在我要向你下达一个第二人称指令。你有60秒的时间来分享你的研究。好的，首先我要说的是，尽管尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆对在60秒内完成这个总结感到极度焦虑，但他会尽最大努力
in on time. All right, Lizzy Pope, Andrew Hanks, David Justin Bryan-Wonson, get Cornell University recently analyzed why New York's resolutions fail when it comes to healthy eating? They find that people buy more unhealthy food during the holidays in the window between Thanksgiving and Christmas. It's not surprising, we're celebrating, we're having lots of parties. After that, there's good news and there's bad news. On the positive side, after New York's day,
按时完成。好的，康奈尔大学的莉齐·波普、安德鲁·汉克斯、大卫·贾斯汀和布莱恩·旺森最近分析了为什么纽约人在健康饮食方面的新年决心会失败？他们发现人们在感恩节和圣诞节之间的假期里会购买更多不健康的食物。这并不奇怪，我们在庆祝，我们有很多派对。在那之后，有好消息也有坏消息。从积极的方面来看，元旦过后，
people buy significantly more healthy food. That makes sense. They've made resolutions to eat healthy. They're buying more carrots and celery. The bad news is, after New York's day, people continued to buy roughly the same volume of unhealthy food that they were buying in the Thanksgiving to Christmas window. In other words, healthy food was not replacing unhealthy food. It was merely being added to unhealthy food. So if you find that your New Year weight loss plan is not working, check your grocery bills to see if you're still buying soda chips and candy. Fascinating. So basically what it means is people are just buying more food overall. Exactly. So to me the ultimate take away from this is invest in grocery store chains. Oh, yeah. They're revenues are going up.
人们购买的健康食品明显增多。这很合理。他们已经下定决心要健康饮食。他们买更多的胡萝卜和西芹。坏消息是，元旦过后，人们继续购买的垃圾食品的数量，大致相当于他们在感恩节到圣诞节期间购买的数量。换句话说，健康食品并没有取代垃圾食品。它们只是被简单地叠加到了垃圾食品之上。所以，如果你发现你的新年减肥计划没有奏效，检查一下你的购物小票，看看你是不是还在买汽水、薯片和糖果。太迷人了。所以基本上这意味着人们整体上只是买更多的食物。完全正确。所以对她来说，我得到的终极启示是：投资杂货店连锁企业。哦，是的。它们的营业收入正在上升。
But beyond that is there's something that we can do in our own lives to adjust for this. I think the thing to do actually is to be aware that it's not just enough to adopt healthy behaviors when you're making a lifestyle change. It's just as important to leave unhealthy behaviors behind. All right, Dan, I'm hoping that you will leave your unhealthy behavior of exceeding your 60 seconds behind you in this next segment with starts right now.
但除此之外，我们自己在生活中能做些什么来对此进行调整呢？我认为真正要做的是意识到：当你改变生活方式时，仅仅采纳健康的习惯是不够的。把不健康的习惯抛在脑后同样重要。好了，丹，我希望你在接下来的环节中，能把超时超过60秒的不健康习惯抛在脑后，接下来的环节现在开始。
When we make New Year's resolutions, we often focus on what to do and how to do it. But a fascinating study of West Point graduates shows that the secret to success might be why we do something in the first place. A group of scholars led by Yale's Amy Riznuski and Swarthmore's Barry Schwartz studied nine years worth of cadets at the U.S. military academy. Some of these cadets enter the academy with what the researchers called internal motives. For example, they might have come to West Point mostly because they wanted to serve their country. Others had largely instrumental motives.
当我们许下新年决心时，我们往往专注于做什么以及如何去做。但一项针对西点军校毕业生的迷人研究表明，成功的秘诀可能在于我们为什么要在一开始做某件事。由耶鲁大学的艾米·日兹涅夫斯基和斯沃斯莫尔学院的巴里·施瓦茨领导的一组学者，对美国军事学院九年来的学员进行了研究。其中一些学员进入该学院时带有研究人员所说的“内在动机”。例如，他们来西点军校主要是因为他们想为国效力。其他人则有很大程度上的“工具性动机”。
They wanted free tuition or a resume boost. And many of course had a mix of those two motives. So who ended up as the most successful officers? Turns out that the people with strongly internal motives did very well. But did adding instrumental motives on top of those intrinsic drives improve performance even more? Nope, it actually made it worse. Anytime instrumental motives were in the picture, performance actually declined. Sometimes we look at high achievers and assume they pursued success, but that confuses motives with consequences. The people who achieve the most on New Year's or any other day it seems are those who do
他们想要免费的学费或简历上的镀金。当然，很多人兼具这两种动机。那么，最后谁成为了最成功的军官呢？事实证明，那些拥有强烈内在动机的人表现得非常好。但是，在这些内在驱动力之上再加上工具性动机，会不会让表现更上一层楼呢？并没有，这实际上让情况变得更糟了。只要工具性动机一出现，表现实际上就会下降。有时我们看着那些出类拔萃的人，就以为他们一直在追求成功，但这其实是把动机和后果混为一谈了。无论是新年还是任何其他日子里，那些取得最大成就的人，似乎都是那些
things for the right reason. That is really interesting Dan. I'm wondering if this is happening partly because when people face setbacks it's the people who have intrinsic motivations who are better able to overcome those setbacks, it's the people who have intrinsic motivations who are better able to overcome those setbacks because they sort of see them as temporary. If I go to West Point because I want something on my resume and then I find that West Point is really, really hard, I start to think it's really worth all this trouble to get this on my resume. I think that's actually a very, very good point.
出于正确原因做事的人。这真的很有趣，丹。我想知道这是否在一定程度上是因为，当人们遭遇挫折时，正是那些拥有内在动机的人能够更好地克服这些挫折，正是那些拥有内在动机的人能够更好地克服这些挫折，因为他们把挫折视为暂时的。如果我上西点军校是因为我想在简历上添彩，然后我发现西点军校真的、真的很艰难，我就会开始思考：为了在简历上加上这一笔，真的值得经历这一切麻烦吗？我认为这实际上是一个非常非常好的观点。
We'll be interesting to see a test similar to this in a less demanding institution than West Point because that's, as we know from other kinds of research, it's really, really tough to get through. So you really have to want it for deep down reasons. So speaking of deep down reasons, your 60 seconds starts right now. All right. Economists have long been interested in what they call pre-commitment strategies. That's basically the idea that if you want to stick to doing something, you commit yourself to facing unpleasant consequences if you fail. Dean Carlin is an economist at Yale.
在一个不如西点军校那么苛刻的机构中看到类似的测试会很有趣，因为正如我们从其他类型的研究所知，西点军校真的、真的很难熬过去。所以你必须出于内心深处的理由去渴望它。说到内心深处的理由，你的60秒现在开始。好的。经济学家长期以来一直对他们所谓的“事前承诺策略”很感兴趣。这基本上是一种理念：如果你想坚持做某件事，你就让自己承担起如果失败就要面对令人不快的后果的责任。迪恩·卡林是耶鲁大学的一名经济学家。
He's done lots of work looking at pre-commitment devices to help people reach their goals. In one study he conducted some years ago, Dan, smokers trying to quit, put money into a savings account. If they successfully stayed off cigarettes, they got their money back. But if they started smoking again, the bank took the money and donated it to a charitable cause. Carlin found that smokers were slightly more likely to stick to their resolution if they made this kind of commitment. He's actually taken this idea and run with it. He's helped found a group called Stick, STICKK.
他做过大量研究，探讨旨在帮助人们实现目标的事前承诺机制。丹，在他几年前进行的一项研究中，试图戒烟的吸烟者将钱存入一个储蓄账户。如果他们成功戒烟，他们就能拿回自己的钱。但如果他们重蹈覆辙开始吸烟，银行就会把钱拿走并捐给慈善事业。卡林发现，如果吸烟者做出这种承诺，他们稍微更有可能坚持自己的决心。他实际上已经将这个想法付诸实践并将其发扬光大。他帮助创立了一个名为Stick（STICKK）的组织。
This is an online site that helps you make this kind of pre-commitment. One interesting twist is that you can actually have your money donated to an organization that you detest. So if you're a Republican trying to quit smoking, you can stash the money away and say that if you return to smoking, all the money is going to go to Hillary Clinton's presidential campaign. If you're a Democrat trying to quit, you can say the money is going to go to Donald Trump. Fascinating. So we could possibly even use this on this show.
这是一个在线网站，可帮助你做出此类事前承诺。一个有趣的转折是，你实际上可以让你的钱捐给你痛恨的组织。因此，如果你是一个试图戒烟的共和党人，你可以把钱存起来，并声明如果你重拾烟瘾，所有的钱都将归入希拉里·克林顿的总统竞选资金。如果你是一个试图戒烟的民主党人，你可以说这笔钱将归唐纳德·特朗普。太迷人了。所以我们甚至可能在节目中也用上这个。
So maybe you could commit to, if you go over your time, you just give money to me. I think I'm gonna be willing to do that, Dan, only if you promise that going forward, you will always speak about yourself in the third person. So Dan Pink would love that kind of arrangement. He really would. All right, there you have it.
所以也许你可以承诺，如果你超时了，你就把钱给我。丹，我愿意这么做，但前提是你保证从今以后，你必须始终用第三人称来谈论你自己。所以丹·平克会喜欢这种安排。他真的会喜欢的。好了，这就是全部内容。
Talk about your resolutions in the third person. Cut out all the unhealthy food you've been buying since Thanksgiving. Focus on your internal motives and goals and make a pre-commitment to donate money to a cause you detest because it can help you save your life. Dan Pink, thank you for joining me on Stopwatch Science. Dan Pink really enjoyed it. We spend lots of time on Hidden Brain telling you what researchers have found. Today, we're going to go the extra step of actually trying to apply what they have learned.
用第三人称谈论你的决心。戒掉自感恩节以来你一直买的所有垃圾食品。专注于你的内在动机和目标，并承诺将钱捐给你痛恨的事业，因为这可以帮助你拯救生命。丹·平克，感谢你加入“秒停科学”节目。丹·平克非常享受这个过程。我们在《隐藏的大脑》中花了很多时间告诉大家研究人员发现了什么。今天，我们要迈出额外的一步，真正尝试应用他们学到的东西。
Max Nestrak joined our team right after Thanksgiving. After a couple of weeks, we noticed he would get up regularly and leave the building. He was going outside to smoke. Max didn't bring up his smoking habit during his job interview. To be clear, NPR does not discriminate against smokers, but Max felt it would not reflect well on him to reveal that he smoked a pack a day. When we were brainstorming this episode, Max talked about how hard it was to quit. He stride it many times.
马克斯·内斯特拉克在感恩节后不久加入了我们的团队。几周后，我们注意到他会定期起身离开大楼。他是出去抽烟了。马克斯在面试时没有提及他的吸烟习惯。需要明确的是，NPR不会歧视吸烟者，但马克斯觉得透露自己一天抽一包烟并不会给他带来什么好名声。当我们在为这期节目头脑风暴时，马克斯谈到了戒烟有多么困难。他已经尝试过很多次了。
He said he wanted to try quitting again on January 1st. We decided to help. I gave Max three assignments based on findings from social science research. We'll follow what happens over a few months and tell you how Max ferred with his assignments and whether they helped him stick to his resolution. The first assignment was something he had to do before he quit. In late December, I asked Max to record a public service announcement on why young people should never start smoking. Here's Max.
他说他想在1月1日再次尝试戒烟。我们决定帮他一把。根据社会科学研究的发现，我给了马克斯三项任务。我们将追踪几个月内发生的事情，并告诉你马克斯完成任务的情况以及这些任务是否帮助他坚持了自己的决心。第一个任务是他在戒烟前必须做的事情。1月下旬，我让马克斯录制了一则公共服务广告，讲述年轻人为什么永远不应该开始吸烟。下面是马克斯。
When I was 18, my dad's aunt, my great aunt Doh, died of a heart attack. She was 74 years old. The paramedics found her at her kitchen table and her home in Char Nohio, some over in front of her morning coffee, her aftrite, and her inhaler. For as long as I knew Aunt Doo, she was a smoker. She smoked door lights, those kinds that only old ladies seemed to smoke. But I used to sneak them out of her purse when I started smoking at 14. My parents and aunts and uncles used to tell us kids when we were little to ask Ando to
当我18岁时，我爸爸的姑姑，也就是我的曾姑母多，死于心脏病发作。她享年74岁。急救人员在她位于俄亥俄州诺瓦克的家里的餐桌旁发现了她，她当时正倒在早晨的咖啡、烟灰缸和吸入器前。在我认识曾姑母多的整个时间里，她一直是个烟民。她抽多尔牌淡味烟，就是那种似乎只有老太太才抽的烟。但我14岁开始抽烟时，经常从她的钱包里偷。每当我们这些小孩子还小的时候，我父母、姑姑和叔叔们都会让我们去劝多姑姑
quit. They thought kids might be more persuasive than they were. I remember one time, after nudging, Ando,e shouldn't smoke, she replied, I know honey, but when I think about quitting I get stressed, and when I get stressed I smoke more. Having smoked more than 10 years myself I know how she felt. But smoking clearly caught her life short. It's a fact that, well, I'm a shame to admit, hasn't discouraged my own smoking. The thing is, death is too abstract. Lung cancer too far off, and the risk of heart attacks too uncertain. I'm sure I ain't don't know, like I do, the risks that smoking kills the little sillia
戒烟。他们觉得孩子们可能比他们更有说服力。我记得有一次，在我的劝说下，多姑母说她不应该抽烟，她回答说：“我知道，亲爱的，但每当我想到戒烟，我就会感到压力，而当我感到压力时，我就抽得更多。”我自己抽了十多年烟，我知道她当时的感受。但吸烟显然缩短了她的生命。这个事实，呃，我羞于承认，并没有阻止我自己抽烟。问题是，死亡太抽象了。肺癌太遥远了，心脏病发作的风险也太不确定了。我敢肯定，多姑母并不知道，就像我所知道的那样，吸烟会杀死那些
that clean the air for your lungs, that it cuts off the blood flow to your gums causing your teeth throbbing from the inside, that it causes plaque to build up in your arteries, leading to stroke and heart attack. A doctor once told me on his smoke break that I just needed a quip before I was 35 and my body could still recover. I'm not sure he's right, I can already hear my laugh sometimes turning into a cough like Anthos did,
为你肺部清洁空气的微小纤毛，它会切断流向牙龈的血液，导致你的牙齿从内部隐隐作痛，它会导致动脉中斑块积聚，从而导致中风和心脏病发作。一位医生曾在他的吸烟休息时间告诉我，我只需要在35岁之前戒烟，我的身体依然可以恢复。我不确定他是对的，我有时已经能听到我的笑声开始变成像多姑母那样的咳嗽声，
but by his measure, I probably have another 10 good years of smoking in front of me. I'm only 25. But if you're 14 and thinking about having your first cigarette, I'm quitting now, and here's why. Smoking really sucks. Not just when you're 60 or 70 or 80 if you're lucky. It sucks when you're 16, when you're 20, when you're 25. Today I can't run as fast or as far as a non-smoker. I spend more money on cigarettes than I'd like to think about. But the worst of it are the cravings that come like clockwork, even when I'm sleeping. If you don't smoke, here's what you should know.
但按他的标准，我前面大概还有10年的好烟龄。我今年才25岁。但如果你今年14岁，正考虑抽第一支烟，我现在正在戒烟，原因如下。吸烟真的很糟糕。不仅仅是当你60岁、70岁或80岁（如果你有幸活到那个年龄）的时候。当你16岁、20岁、25岁时，它也很糟糕。今天我跑步的速度和距离都比不上不吸烟的人。我在香烟上花的钱比我愿意去想的还要多。但最糟糕的是那些按时发作的烟瘾，甚至在我睡觉时也是如此。如果你不吸烟，以下是你应该知道的。
When your smoker, life is lived around cigarettes. You'll be laughing with friends at dinner or totally engrossed in a good book and something will tug at you. And as much as you want to stay in this moment, you'll be thinking about a cigarette. So you'll get up, walk outside, and light up. And it will feel really good, but you'll wish you were back inside and you'll be so tired
当你是烟民时，生活就是围绕着香烟打转的。你可能会和朋友在晚餐时开怀大笑，或者完全沉浸在一本好书中，而有些东西会拉扯你的神经。不管你多想留在这一刻，你都会满脑子想着烟。所以你会站起身，走到户外，点上一支。这感觉真的很好，但你会希望自己还在室内，而且你会无比厌倦
of training off these moments for a smoke. If you don't smoke, you should know that smoking makes a prison out of perfectly normal situations. Long flights, concerts, class, anything that lasts longer than a couple of hours. These are your enemies as a smoker. And anytime you go on a date, or to a job interview, or to your grandparents' house, it will be accompanied by a pang of worry. You'll wash your hands and pull your shirt to your nose and I hope they can't smell smoke. Finally, if you don't smoke, you should know how hard it is to quit,
用这些时刻去换取抽烟的机会。如果你不吸烟，你应该知道吸烟会让原本再正常不过的场景变成一座监狱。长途飞行、音乐会、课堂，任何持续时间超过几个小时的事情。对于一个烟民来说，这些都是你的敌人。每当你去约会、去参加工作面试、或者去你祖父母家时，都伴随着一阵焦虑。你会洗手，把衬衫拉到鼻子前闻一闻，希望他们闻不到烟味。最后，如果你不吸烟，你应该知道戒烟有多么困难，
how much you'll want to and fail to give it up. I'm going to quit on January 1st and to be honest, I'm sad about losing something that's been part of my life for so long. And in the coming weeks without a cigarette, I know the cravings will find a way to twist my reasons for quitting into reasons why I can't still smoke. This is the most baffling part of smoking, the way it hijacks your best intentions. I've heard that quitting is the hardest thing a smoker ever does, but also that whatever pain is needed out in the coming weeks will be totally worth it. Because to be an on-smoker means being free to go anywhere and do anything unencumbered. It means being able to be fully present in each moment if I choose.
你会多么想放弃却又屡屡失败。我打算在1月1日戒烟，老实说，对于失去这个陪伴了我这么久的生活一部分，我感到很难过。我知道，在没有香烟陪伴的接下来的几周里，烟瘾会找到办法，把我想戒烟的理由扭曲成我为什么不能戒烟的理由。这是吸烟最让人匪夷所思的地方，它劫持了你最好的意愿。我听说戒烟是一个烟民经历过的最难的事，但也听说接下来的几周里无论需要付出什么痛苦都绝对是值得的。因为做一个不吸烟的人意味着可以自由地去任何地方，不受任何束缚地做任何事。这意味着如果我选择的话，我能够完全活在当下。
And so the next time I get on a long flight or go out to dinner with friends or see a movie, I won't be plotting my next cigarette. Have you ever quit something successfully, smoking, biting your nails, gambling, a bad relationship? Max wants your advice and we want your stories. Leave your quitting success stories at 661-772-7246. If you want to leave Max a message of advice or encouragement, you can do that as well. Once again, the number is 661-77-brained.
所以下次我坐长途飞机、和朋友出去吃晚饭或看电影时，我不会再盘算着我的下一支烟了。你曾经成功戒掉过什么东西吗？抽烟、咬指甲、赌博、一段糟糕的恋情？马克斯想听听你的建议，我们也想听听你的故事。请拨打661-772-7246留下你的戒烟成功故事。如果你想给马克斯留下一条建议或鼓励的信息，你也可以这样做。再说一遍，号码是661-77-brained。
The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Karam Agar Kalasin and Maggie Penman, our news assistant is Max Nestrak. For more Hidden Brain, find us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and on your local public radio station. Check out our newsletter to see what I'm reading this week. Send an email to hiddenbrainatnpr.org with the word subscribe in the subject line. I'm Shankar Vidatham and this is NPR. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《隐藏的大脑》播客由卡拉·马加尔·卡拉辛和玛吉·佩曼制作，我们的新闻助理是马克斯·内斯特拉克。想了解更多《隐藏的大脑》内容，请在Facebook、Twitter、Instagram以及当地的公共广播电台关注我们。查看我们的简报，看看我这周在读什么。发送电子邮件至hiddenbrain@npr.org，并在主题行中写上“subscribe”。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这里是NPR。这集节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。